travis shane congratulations once again
you find yourselves in the final round
of this competition now we're sending
you back to your home forges where you
will make an iconic blade from history
the potter
the pata was a unique gauntlet weapon
developed by the marathas of central
india this double-edged weapon had a
long flexible blade over four feet long
the pada was so distinctive it was
featured in the cult classic film willow
instead of featuring a guard like most
swords it had a steel gauntlet that
would cover the hand and sometimes even
the forearm with their arms strapped
inside of the gauntlet the user would
not have the use of their wrist
therefore a soldier equipped with a pot
and needed experience in using such a
unique weapon
while the pata was commonly used by
mounted warriors its design allowed even
a soldier on foot to strike from a wider
variety of angles compared to a
conventional sword
good luck champs we'll see you in five
days
good luck
this is a challenge the champion of
champions i have to push the envelope i
have to make this store the best that i
can make it i'm gonna gamble i'm going
for damascus
i'm starting with 17 layers and i
actually want to get to 200 layers
there's no quick and easy way to make
damascus there's a process it has to go
through and it's just time consuming for
that pattern to pop i think i have to go
above and beyond
i'm going to make an impression in this
block of wood kind of the same shape of
the back of my hand
i've never forged a gauntlet so
i'm limited on tools i'm limited on
knowledge will have to be done by
eyeballing by hand
i'm definitely happy to be back in my
own shop because i make tools for a
living and i've been working on some
neat little gadgets and gizmos that i
think will be pretty handy
this is not a standard forging fire
because i'm going up against shane
carter i'm gonna have to bring a nice
piece because he's no slouch
can't go wrong with 5160.
the pot is a broadsword blade that
linked the sword blade to the forearm to
generate power through the elbow and
shoulder
i can i can i'm starting to see this
being
this is going to be some
we're going to mess up some
it's day two i'm going to spend most of
the day working on that gauntlet i have
ideas in my mind but i don't have a
clear picture what the finished product
is going to be
i think that's going to be pretty close
actually fabricating a knuckle
fabricating the human hand is a tough
challenge
they're starting to look more like a
fist now i'm just gonna have to get the
d guard fit to the sword
we're getting there slowly but surely
well it's day three and i'm ready to
quench my blade
well here we go what i consider the most
important part of this build is the
hardening of the blade if it's soft it's
not going to hold an edge if you hit
something you don't want to stay bent i
would like to do some testing
[Music]
tough man
so day four and the swords come along
very nicely if i had one comment i would
say it's probably just a little bit
heavy but i went the extra mile with the
pattern to give travis a run for his
money i'm actually feeling pretty good
by the end of the day i want to have my
blade assembled
i've got the blade in the vise and i'm
welding it up i'm getting it fastened
and
and a spark jumps out and bingo just
just fries the cutting edge to my blade
that means i'll have to reprofile the
blade re-etch it if i don't reprofile it
i could have a soft spot there as well
it's definitely a disappointment because
the geometry and the aesthetics of the
blade are compromised but all i can do
is move forward
today's day five and i'd be lying if i
said i wasn't nervous i still got to
build my whole gauntlet so if i make 14
gauge i'll make wider just make this so
if i make a bigger 16 gauge i can just
tell the whole thing
on a day like this i think i could have
held a needle in my ass for 10 hours
straight
i have the fist of the gauntlet i welded
that to the arm piece of the gauntlet i
welded that to the guard
to the hand piece
i still got to put a strap in i want a
freaking sheepskin in it all right all
right let's go time is running out
that's going to make a mess but i don't
care
oh this is going to suck
god last 10 minutes was up
all right
all right that works
[Applause]
oh that piece
i wish i could take that discoloration
off i'm out of time right
okay then i'm done right
to see how sharp your weapons are i will
take your pata and i'll deliver three
sharp blows on these meat carcasses
travis you're up first you ready might
as well
i feel pretty good going into weapons
testing i know my blade has good
geometry and it's comfortable
well done
okay travis
very nice clean lines with your blade
on the motion it's got great recovery a
little bit heavy for the gauntlet there
but it is wicked sharp your weapon
will cut thank you good job
all right shane you're up next you ready
yes sir
well shane
off the bat it's very heavy hard to
handle in terms of the recovery your
blade is gorgeous though beautiful
damascus pattern in terms of sharpness
it did almost cut through the two pieces
over there cut all the way through the
center piece so this blade will cut
thank you
now patel in combat had to be sharp but
it also had to be strong so to test your
blade's strength we're going to put it
in our vise and then flex it both
directions to 20 degrees
if your blade's strong it should return
to true
travis you're up first are you ready yep
here we go i'm pretty nervous right now
anytime somebody shoves your tip in a
vice and goes bending on it you can't
help but think something bad is gonna
happen
20.
looks good so far
all right travis you know everything is
still right and tight up here your
connection to the gauntlets very solid
good job thank you
all right shane your turn
let's do it
just 10
20.
all right going the other way
ten
oh twenty
all right well shane i was actually
worried
more about the connection right here
flexing
since you've got it supported on that
one side
but your blade
is true
thank you to see how much lethal damage
your weapon can do i will deliver some
killing blows on this big carcass travis
you're up first ready sure
[Music]
travis
your design of your pata feels good when
you're thrusting it went all the way
through the carcass
on a diagonal slice
almost cut all the way through the pig
carcass
overall sir your blade
will kill
good job thank you
all right shane you're up next ready yes
sir let's do this
[Music]
okay shane your edge geometry on your
blade it's on the thicker side
so it tends to
chop as opposed to slice through
but in terms of a thrust like that in
cuts
it's very lethal those kinds of damages
will kill good job thank you
travis shane
the forged and fired champion of
champions is
travis congratulations
shane
this time your blade did not make the
cut shane we asked you to turn an iconic
weapon from history what you turned in
is fitting of a fortune fired champion
but the weight and edge geometry of your
blade affected its performance
it underperformed the sharpness and kill
test it's for that reason we're letting
you go
shane
please surrender your weapon
travis built a better weapon than i
built i got beat thank you gentlemen
it's been an honor to come back as a
champion the reason i came back is to
become a better blade smith and that's
what forged in fire does so when i get
home i'm going to spend time with my
family and get back to work travis you
beat out three others to become our
champion of champions congratulations
you will also be receiving a check for
ten thousand dollars good job
[Applause]
this is awesome shane is a very skilled
guy
and it was really neat competing against
him
it felt really good winning fours and
fire once
and to be able to do it again and say
that the champion of champions
is a pretty neat field but i gotta head
home and build some grinders
you